[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sommes nous des êtres à tion nel des
êtres qui passons notre temps à faire de
petits calculs intérieur coûts bénéfices
sans même nous en rendre compte qu'est
ce que cela me rapporte de faire ceci
qu'est ce que cela me coûte en
contrepartie et bien nous les
économistes nous pensons que oui nous
avons même inventé pour cela un modèle
un être fictif
l'homo
economicus c'est un modèle extrêmement
puissant qui permet de comprendre nombre
de petites décisions de votre vie de
notre vie quotidienne vais-je aller à
nice en avion ou en train cette semaine
est-ce que je reste en télétravail
ou est-ce que je vais au bureau ce soir
je regarde un match de foot tranquille
chez moi où je vais chez des amis pour
ses choix apparemment anodin sans même
le savoir nous livrons un petit calcul
intérieur
pour vous en convaincre prenons un
premier exemple l'exemple de jeanne
jeanne est une jeune lycéenne qui vient
d'avoir son baccalauréat elle se demande
légitimement exclu devrait pas faire des
études supérieures et bien jane va
s'engager dans un petit calcul coûts
bénéfices jane va se dire
mais si je fais une année d'études
supplémentaire je vais être plus
qualifiés j'aurai donc un meilleur
salaire tout au long de ma vie et
j'aurais peut-être accès à des métiers
beaucoup plus intéressant mais jeunes va
également se dire oui mais attention si
je continuais les études supérieures à
tout d'abord ça n'est pas gratuit de
faire des études mais surtout tout le
temps que je vais passer à faire des
études c'est autant de temps pendant
lequel je ne vais pas occupé un travail
et donc percevoir salle
jane va donc faire un petit calcul coûts
bénéfices si elle estime que le gain
d'une année d'études supplémentaire
l'emportent sur le coup alors elle
s'engagera dans des études
symétriquement si jal estime que le coût
d'une année d'études supplémentaire
l'emportent sur le gain qu'elle arrêtera
de faire des études bref jeanne se
comportent en homo economicus
prenois second exemple celui d'alan alan
est un jeune cadre dynamique plein
d'ambitions pour son entreprise est un
peu pour lui même
alan se demande comment il pourrait
augmenter des profits de son entreprise
est une idée lui est venue pourquoi
est-ce que je ne proposerai pas à mes
concurrents que l'on fixe ensemble les
prix cela s'appelle en économie un
cartel c'est interdit par la loi est
sévèrement réprimée
alan lui aussi comme jane va se livrer
un petit calcul d'intérieur coûts
bénéfices
commençons par les gains des bénéfices
alan va se dire mais si je fais une
entente un cartel les profils mon
entreprise vont augmenter mais si le
profit mon entreprise augmente je vais
percevoir une prime un bonus j'aurais
peut-être même un avancement de carrière
mais alan va se dire également aussitôt
harry mais attention il y a un coût du
coup c'est d'abord de se faire attraper
et de se prendre une sanction
sévère alan d'ailleurs s'il vit aux
etats-unis courent même un risque
personnel celui de faire un séjour en
prison
alan tout comme jane va mettre en
balance des gains et les coups avant de
commettre éventuellement une infraction
en réalité à l'âne est confronté à une
équation aussi simple que redoutable une
équation qui a valu à son auteur gary
becker le prix nobel d'économie
de gains de l'infraction c'est à dire le
profit illicite l'emportent sur le coup
qu'est ce que le coup c'est la
probabilité de se faire attraper x le
gain espéré alors il enfreindra la loi
bref nous voyons travers des exemples de
jeanne
d'alan que vous moi nous sommes tous peu
ou prou des homo economicus oui nous
faisons de petits calculs intérieur même
si nous n'avons pas toujours conscience
oui mais il ya un mais il ya un mais
dans tout ce que je viens de vous dire
je dirais même qu'il y a un gros mais
c'est lorsque nous faisons ces petits
calculs nous le faisons toujours dans un
contexte donné qui va influencer notre
perception des gars et des coûts d'autre
part nous ne sommes pas pur esprit nous
sommes des êtres d'émotions de
sensations nous pouvons être victime de
biais cognitifs c'est bien beau
influencer modifier parfois faux c'est
notre perception des gains et des coûts
bref
sociologie et psychologie
vont s'inviter à la table de l'homo
economicus
commençons par le contexte nous ne
vivons pas vous ne vivez pas je ne vis
pas hors du mans nous sommes dans une
société avec des valeurs des normes une
éducation des interdits une morale nous
avons des camarades des collègues de
travail une famille des amis bref
lorsque nous prenons une décision nous
sommes toujours inséré dans un contexte
particulier
tenez reprenons l'exemple de jeanne vous
sourient les jeunes cette jeune lycéenne
qui se demande si elle doit s'engager
dans des études supérieures
jeanne est issu d'un milieu défavorisé
et dans une classe où il ya beaucoup de
mauvaise élève et jade entend depuis
longtemps une petite musique en dépit
des encouragements répétés de ses
professeurs tu sais les études
supérieures c'est pas pour nous
c'est pas pour toi
jeanne est donc dans un contexte qui va
la conduire naturellement à
sous-estimer le gain c'est à dire la
rentabilité des études supérieures
tenait d'ailleurs six jeunes avaient été
dans un milieu favorisé ou dans une
classe avec beaucoup de bon élève très
ambitieux jeanne aurait sans doute eu
une perception assez différentes des
gains et des cours
prenons l'exemple d'alan vous souvenez
alan ce jeune cadre dynamique plein
d'ambitions pour son entreprise et pour
lui même et qui se demande s'il ne
devrait pas peut-être enfreindre les
règles de droit
à la ddt lui aussi dans un contexte il
ne vit pas hors du monde il est dans une
entreprise une entreprise qui a sans
doute une charte des valeurs un code de
bonne conduite il a des collègues des
supérieurs hiérarchiques
management des actionnaires bref il
travaille dans une entreprise
particulière imaginez que dans son
entreprise les règles du jeu soient
claires dès le départ
dans notre entreprise aucune infraction
aux règles de droit quelle qu'elle soit
ne saura tôt les rives autant vous dire
que alan aura une claire perception des
coûts si par contre à l'année dans une
entreprise où on pratique le laisser
faire une certaine bienveillance
négligente où ses collègues ministres tu
sais certes enfreindre la loi c'est
illégal mais c'est un mal nécessaire
finalement pour poursuivre un but qui
est tout à fait licite faire du profit
alan aura peut-être une perception moins
critique des coûts tenez prenons même un
cas aussi rare
qu'extrême que nous appelons le cas
d'inversion
des valeurs
imaginez que ses collègues lui répète à
longueur de journée tu sais alan la
concurrence c'est la guerre parce que la
concurrence et la guerre des entreprises
contre les entreprises on prend les
clients de ses concurrents
alors que si on fait une entente si on
fait un cartel on se répartit les
clients c'est la paix
lane tu préfères la guerre à la paix
vous allez me dire tout cela est de la
théorie économique non il ya un peu plus
de vingt ans un grand cartel a été
détectés aux états unis et condamné
voici qu'elle était la devise des
membres du cartel je cite ouvrez les
guillemets nos concurrents ce sont nos
amis nos clients ce sont nos ennemis
bel exemple d'aversion les valeurs n'ont
d'ailleurs à l'âne ne va pas enfreindre
la règle de droit du jour au lendemain
il va participer à des réunions avec ses
concurrents et ils ont tout à fait
licite et puis un jour
das invité dans la discussion le sujet
de l'entente à la lgv à enfreindre la
loi sans même en avoir une claire
conscience il va enfreindre
progressivement la reine ce qui va le
conduire à minorer le coup de
l'infraction bref que voyons nous au
travers des exemples de jeanne d'alan
pourtant si différent que lorsque nous
devons faire ses petits calculs
intérieur nous sommes souvent dépendant
du contexte dans lequel nous les faisons
mais nous sommes également parfois
victimes ou en tout cas dépendant
d'autres biais de billets psychologique
vous savez ces biais psychologiques ont
été étudiés depuis très très longtemps
pas seulement par les psychologues
également par l'économie comportementale
ce qui a valu d'ailleurs à leurs auteurs
le prix nobel
parmi les nombreux biais psychologiques
j'en prendrai deux
commençons par le biais de disponibilité
vous savez quand vous devez faire un
choix prendre une décision quand vous
jeu nous avons toujours tendance à
surestimer l'apparition des événements
les plus visibles ou les plus récents
al'inverse nous avons tendance à minorer
l'occurrence l'existence des événements
que l'on ne voit pas ou qui sont plus
anciens parfois même on pense qu'un
exode un événement que ne voit pas
n'existe tout simplement pas
reprenons l'exemple de jeanne ou sauver
cette jeune lycéenne qui se demande si
elle va s'engager dans des études
supérieures
janet dans un issu d'un milieu
défavorisé dans sa famille dans ses amis
dans son quartier elle ne voit pas de
personnes qui ont fait des études
supérieures et donc jeanne fort
légitimement se dit mais à quoi bon
faire des études supérieures je ne vois
pas autour de moi des personnes qu'ils
se soient engagés dans une telle
démarche elle va donc avoir tendance à
sous-estimer le rendement de l'éducation
tout simplement parce qu'elle est
victime d'un billet de
disponibilité je n'en vois pas autour de
moi donc en réalité ça n'existe pas
vraiment d'ailleurs ce qui vaut pour
jeanne
beau pour de nombreux jeunes je pense en
particulier à tous ces jeunes qui savent
et qui rêve de carrière à succès devenir
chanteurs footballeurs youtuber il voit
la télévision ces stars du foot de la
chanson qui gagnent des millions ils
sont célèbres et se disent mais moi
aussi je veux être comme eux et je serai
célèbre oui mais il oublie
parce qu'ils n'en ont pas connaissance
parce qu'ils n'en ont pas conscience
qu'il ya des millions de footballeurs
youtuber d'acteurs de chanteurs qu'il
des fins de mois difficiles
al'inverse de jeanne ils vont être
victimes d'un billet de disponibilité
qui va les conduire à surestimer
la rentabilité de ces métiers
second billet le biais de cirque chance
vous savez quand nous devons faire un
choix coûts bénéfices nous avons
toujours tendance à considérer que nous
allons maîtriser les issues n'est plus
favorable dit en d'autres termes nous
pensons tous que nous sommes plus
intelligents que les autres c'est à dire
que la moyenne
revenons sur al ahd vous souvenez alan
ce jeune cadre dynamique plein
d'ambitions pour son entreprise et pour
lui-même à la dette aussi très éduquée
et alan se dit mais comme je suis éduqué
je maîtrise d'un savoir je maîtrise une
connaissance je ne me ferai pas prendre
j'échapperais à la détection et donc je
peux faire une entente puisque j'ai les
moyens intellectuels de ne pas me faire
détecter j'utiliserai des téléphone
crypté des noms de code
tenez vous bien une expérience a été
menée sur un échantillon de manager on
leur a fait jouer un jeu de cartes l on
s'est aperçu que ce qu'ils enfreignaient
la loi était ce qu'ils maîtrisaient les
règles du jeu
paradoxalement le fait de détenir une
expertise un savoir vous rend invincible
ou plutôt vous donne un sentiment
d'invincibilité
et donc alan va être victime d'un billet
de sueur confiance qui va le conduire à
surestimer le gain de l'infraction et à
sous-estimer son coup d'ailleurs ce qui
pour alan qui disons le clairement est
potentiellement un délinquant en col
blanc vo de manière générale pour toute
personne qui entend
enfreindre les règles de droit je pense
en particulier aux personnes qui
rentrent dans la petite délinquance
ou petits dealers de nombreuses études
empiriques ont montré que très souvent
les petits dealers les petits
délinquants étaient victimes de ce biais
de sueur confiance je ne me ferais
jamais prendre ce qui les conduit à
majorer les gains et à minorer découpe
bref que voyons nous nous voyons que
nous sommes aussi souvent victimes nord
ce que nous faisons ce calcul coût
bénéfice de biais psychologiques
en réalité
vous moi tout comme jane allan oui nous
sommes des êtres rationnels même si nous
n'avons pas toujours conscience oui nous
sommes désormais économique us mais nous
sommes souvent
victimes du billet de contexte et de
biais psychologiques cela vaut pour les
petites décisions de la vie quotidienne
mais cela vaut aussi pour les grands
choix de notre vie
vais-je acheter un appartement
ou non
vais-je me marier
ou non vais-je avoir un enfant
ou non pour tous ces choix très
personnel très intime très subjectif je
vous laisse y réfléchir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]